we are now ready to learn about the key
algorithmic technique called dynamic
programming and to learn about the
dynamic programming we will look at a
very simple change problem you walk to a
supermarket you pay for a component
personal book and you have 40 cents and
change and now Kashia is making a
decision how to give you this change the
cash a can give you a quarter a dime an
extra five cents that will be three
coins but Kashia also has a choice of
giving you 40 pennies the change problem
is to find the minimum number of coins
to change a given amount of money and
the first things that come to mind is
actually the approach that cash gets all
over the world use they simply look at
the amount of money they have to change
and define the maximum denomination
maximum amount maximum coins that
doesn't exceed the money they give you
this coin subtract this coin from the
amount of money and iterate the reason
this approach would produce an optimal
solution in fact it will produce an
optimal solution in the United States
but not in Tanzania Tanzania has
beautiful coin shown here and actually
in addition to quarters they have a 20
cent coin so while greedy algorithm in
Tanzania will result in three coins as a
change because it starts from 25 the
largest coin smaller than 40 then at
stanza that's fine the right thing to
change money in Tanzania is simply to
give you two 20 cents coin so what
algorithm should we design to change
money in Tanzania optimally let's design
recursive change algorithm and let's
imagine that we are in a strange country
with only three coin six cents five
cents and one set how would we change
nine cents using this coin well to
change nine cents to find optimal amount
of money or optimal mean number of coins
to change nine cents we can find many
number of coins to change eight cents
and to add one penny or minimum number
of coins change four cents and two and
five cents coin one more coin or to find
minion number of coins to change three
cents and add one more cool right and
therefore minimum number of coins for
nine cents is minimum of minimum number
of coins for eight four or three cents
plasma make sense okay and to but to
find minimum number of coins for three
four and eight cents the once again need
to find minion number of coins for other
values of money and we will be doing
this recursively so the general formula
for whatever number of coins we want we
may have four denomination will be
minimum number of coins for the amount
of money equal minimum of the following
D expressions where D is the number of
coins in the currency is meaning it is
minimum of minion umber of money for
money minus coin one minute number of
money a minute number of coins for money
minus coin - and finally mininum number
of coins for money minus coin D plasma
for all this values and there is a
simple recursive change algorithm for
that implement this approach so every
time we need to change the amount of
coins equal money we have D recursive
calls and compute the minimum number of
change for money minus coin I do you
think it is a good algorithm the solid
will definitely is definitely correct
but it will take quite enormous time to
solve the problem let's see how it works
let's start from 76 cents and see how
algorithm work to compute the change for
76 cents we need to compute first the
change for 70 cents 71 cents and 72
cents right yes 75 cents and the
continues is very recursively and we see
that to compute 76 cents we actually
need to compute optimal amount of change
for 69 cents twice but if we go further
we see that we actually need to computed
more than twice now we see that we need
to compute it five times in reality we
actually need to compute optimal coin
combination for 69 cents 6 times okay so
but how many times do we need to compute
optimal combination for 30 cents
it turns out that we need to computed
trillions of times which means that our
logger it is correct but it will never
end because it takes so much time we
need to come up with is a different
approach instead of changing money
greedily let's try something different
wouldn't be wonderful to compute all the
values minimum number of coins for money
minus coin I that all values that we
need to compute minimum number of coins
for the amount of money if the
precomputed all these values then
computed minimum number of coins for
given amount of money would be a simple
exercise and very fast exercise right
and to implement it the only thing that
we need instead of the time consuming
calls to recursive change for money
minus coin I they simply look up the
values of mininum number of money coins
from
- quite so how our algorithm change will
instead of moving from larger to smaller
values to fill this table we will now
move from small values to larger words
for example what is the minimum number
of coins to change zero cents of course
it is zero what is the minimum number of
coins to change one sense of course it
is 1 2 it is 2 3 it is 3 and 4 it is 4
and now we come to changing five coins
and they can be changed in two different
ways they can be changed either by
taking minimum number of coins to change
0 an 18-point coin or minimum number of
coins to change for an ad in one coin
which of these numbers is smaller this
is a simple check and we choose to
change 5 coin by adding 5 cents coin to
existing combination
now the facing curve is the problem of
changing 6 cents in this case there are
three change choices we can either use
optimal change for five cents or one
cent or zero cents and depending which
of them is the smallest will decide how
to change 6 cents so in this case it
turned out that the best strategy is
simply to add 6 cents coin to the
combination we continue further and
further until we arrive to change and 9
coins of course it is a much faster
algorithm and we can implement it
differently without any recursive coins
simply at every stage to compute the
amount of money we need to run D look at
the previously computed values where D
is the number of denominations that's
all that the idea developed by Richard
Berman and called dynamic programming
which is arguably the most popular
algorithmic technique today amazingly 16
years ago when Richard bellman was
developing the stick
Nik it was absolutely unclear that this
technique has any practical applications
in fact original Varma was working on a
project for air force and it turned out
some students sometimes ask you where is
programming can dynamically mean eternal
there is no programming in dynamic
programming because at that time his
approach he seemed completely
impractical and he worked for air force
so he wanted to hide that he is really
doing mathematics from the Secretary of
Defense he was a prominent mathematician
by this time this is a quote from
Richard bellman what name could I choose
I want I was interested in planning but
planning is not a good word for various
reason I decided therefore to use the
word programming and I wanted to get
across the idea that this was dynamic it
was something not even a congressman
could object to so I use it as an
umbrella for my activities so amazingly
enough the most popular algorithmic
technique today was invented as an
umbrella for the non-messy for
mathematical activity while working on
the airforce project
you